[Music]  one year ago he learned the truth here a  wizard Harry and his first year at  Hogwarts school became legend and so for  Harry Potter and his friends another  year begins  Lottie pads on menace  the education in the magical arts  continues please mr. Finnegan see what  you make of them old rivalries go  stronger as leather and stun your seeker  [Music]  and something in the schools dark past  will be awakened the Chamber of Secrets  has indeed been opened unless the  culprit is caught it is likely the  school will be closed Harry Potter must  go home and they are in trouble here's  the pan you disguise ourselves as Crabbe  and Goyle are we going to drink that yes  [Music]  hurry run excellent  this year Warner Brothers pictures %  where the past will return in the  struggle for the future of our boards  will be game  [Music]  [Applause]  Harry Potter and the Chamber secrets  help mr. Potter will always be around to  save the day  don't worry I will be  [Music]  [Music]  you